if you teach people how to create from
the field instead of from matter they
will shorten the distance between the
thought of what they want and the
experience of having it between the
cause and the effect now think about
three-dimensional reality many people
can develop the skills to become
successful they can make the right
choices they can study real hard they
can practice they can get trained but
they're going to follow certain rules of
Newtonian physics it's just going to
take time you do that for a while and
sooner or later you're going to say is
there another way if it's not matter
that's emitting the field it's the field
that's creating matter if I can change
the information in the field I can
change the expression in
three-dimensional reality so if you can
teach a person to become nobody no one
no thing nowhere in no time to become
pure Consciousness and disconnect and
dissociate from everything physical and
known in their three-dimensional reality
we have data to say that people can do
this now all of a sudden if they become
aware that they can actually connect to
that field with their awareness and
they're not at mylet any longer their
Consciousness their awareness and
infinite emptiness in space it would be
like the illusion is the virtual reality
headset you're taking the headset off
you can't get the upgrade from inside of
it if you could have a coherent heart
and a coherent brain and create from the
field instead of from matter every
thought in the quantum field produces a
frequency if you can feel the frequency
of that thought and you experience it
you're shortening the distance between
the thought of what you want on the
experience of it and you're creating
coherent patterns of energy in the field
that actually change the Hologram in
three-dimensional reality hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because of my first business I quit I'm
a business partner I struggled to keep
going I was making 300 bucks a month and
felt like a complete failure and the
thing that saved me that pulled me up
was studying the stories of famous
entrepreneurs I got the motivation from
them I also got the strategies of what
to do next so that I can go off and
achieve my dreams and quite honestly I
still need the stories today myself to
continue my motivation to take it to the
next level so today let's learn how you
can visualize with Joe dispenza enjoy
so for me personally
I've done a lot of the matter the matter
stuff got really good at it and then I
just said there's got to be another way
so demystify the process I don't care
what you want I don't care if it's a
trip somewhere or a new life or a new
car or whatever people who do this
what do you think they feel
when they see that first synchronicity
you think they'll be like oh
I don't want to meditate tomorrow I'm
going to do this are you kidding the
synchronicity happens in the energy the
surprise wakes the person up and they go
whatever I'm doing inside of me is
producing some effect outside of me and
I better pay attention to what I'm doing
and keep doing it and every human
being's had some glimpse of this at
least some point in their life the point
is that this can be happening on a
regular basis for you the real irony of
all of this is this idea of changing
from matter to matter and then moving
into a higher space where it's energy to
matter
the truth is is that when you get there
if we're going a little bit deeper is
that the very thing that you think you
want to create in matter
you don't really need to create it no
because because listen when you get to
when you start connecting to those
greater frequencies you're moving closer
to source and what is Source pure love
what is it Oneness wholeness whatever
you want to call this it's right there
the whole time it's inevitable it's like
it's the most familiar unfamiliar
feeling you'll ever have and we came
from that place you know we came from
there and so you're in an experiment
called three-dimensional reality
Consciousness in the never-ending
process of self-discovery right and so
now the person who has the synchronicity
who has the coincidence there
this is what I love about our community
more than anything else
they do the work they're not
philosophers they're not theologians
they're not academic they are out of the
bleachers and they're on the playing
field every day they're creating rule
number two reconnect with the source
what are the things that
disturb or
disconnect our Awakening and connection
to the Divine what are those that that
Source or that power that Consciousness
that you are speaking about what are the
things that then disturb or disconnect
us from that once we become connected
because I'm sure many people feel
connected they get it they they get a
breakthrough yeah yeah but then yeah you
know well this is a great question also
I mean I mean um wow I think a lot of
times when people they hit that point
they try to reproduce it the same way as
we talked about and you can't yeah you
can't do it the same way because that's
redundancy but also many times uh we
have the experience and we start to try
and because trying is matter trying to
change matter and and so we're forcing
we're controlling we're predicting and
and then the uh and when we do that then
of course we're in separation and we're
waiting for the event to happen to feel
the emotion right and
I've done that long enough and is
actually have to lay down
the very thing we used our whole life to
get what we want for something greater
to occur and it takes practice of
surrender right so
that's one element I also think that our
response is emotionally like uh uh uh
let's just say that a person gets
connected to the Future like it
connected to the energy of their future
they feel it it's really great and then
they start their day and then two hours
later they're they're feeling something
else because some person or some
circumstance altered their state well
they just disconnected from the energy
of the future and now they're back to
the energy of the past don't expect
anything to change in your life because
it doesn't work that way so then then
when they get back to that old self
again then they say what's wrong with me
I fail they didn't do it right no that's
all the program you show up again and
you go after it again
so familiar feelings uh cause us
to no longer see through the lens of the
future we're seeing through the lens of
the past and and and we color reality
that way so
um I think I think familiar emotions uh
get in the way as well and then of
course there's always belief and a
belief is just a thought you keep
thinking over and over again until you
hardwired in your brain and all beliefs
are based on past experience a person
has an experience the stronger the
emotion they have from that circumstance
the more they pay attention to the cause
and the brain freezes a frame takes a
snapshot and it's called the memory the
moment they draw a conclusion about that
experience they'll think neurologically
within those circuits and they'll feel
chemically within the boundaries of
emotion thinking and feeling thinking
and feeling belief becomes an
unconscious or subconscious state of
being they don't most people don't even
know they have beliefs about things
about God about relationships about
money because it's it's not a conscious
thing it's a subconscious thing yeah so
in order to change a belief or a
perception
about yourself and your life
you got to go all in it's not like you
go 50 and you got to go all in you got
to make a decision
with such firm intention
that the amplitude of that decision
carries a level of energy
that causes the body to respond to the
mind that the choice that you make
becomes a moment in time you'll never
forget and you would say I remember the
moment
I made up my mind to change and the
stronger the emotion you feel the more
you'll pay attention to the decision and
that's a huge Stone you drop in the
quantum field Big Splash big waves and
in essence we're giving the body a taste
emotionally of the future we're aligning
to a new future now how many times do
you have to do that I don't know I've
done it over and over again until it
becomes uncompromising and people say I
remember when I made up my mind to
change I remember I made up my mind to
heal I remember the moment I can tell
you where I was
who I was with what time of day it was
it wasn't like 9 11 something outer
world changing your inner World your
inner world is changing your own world
which is ultimately going to change your
outer world so
I mean people say well I I I I believe
God Lives within me the vine lives
within me okay you sit them down to do a
meditation 10 minutes goes by and
they're hungry and they quit
if you knew the Divine lived within you
you you wouldn't quit you would not you
would you would be like I'm here yeah
and you're gonna go a little deeper a
little further you're gonna get past
your hunger you're gonna get past your
pain you're gonna you're gonna go a
little further because like you want to
know right if you knew it was there so
that's a belief that you're not aware of
right so we all have them I I face them
every day so people have beliefs that
like that the Divine has a has an
opinion about them it's it would never
it's impossible to judge it would divide
itself it can't do that so as we start
having these experiences
I think then our Paradigm shifts many
times at least for me I mean I can't
tell you how many times I've had a
transcendental moment come back to Joe
dispenza and looked at looked out in
this world and I said I got this all
wrong this is not about abstaining from
Life who's the opposite it's about going
all in and really engaging and really
living and really experiencing and
tasting and smelling and eating and
loving and have export here for that
we're here for all of that so you create
the experience
and then when it gets predictable or it
gets boring
let's change it up let's create another
one and then how far can you go with
that it just goes on rule number three
unlock your true Freedom or when you
talk about you know living in the future
and keeping your eye on the future and
and not you know and turning within and
and and not being you know a victim or
at the whim of your external
circumstances that's the goal right
that's the first step to Freedom
um but then you know as all the
enlightened Masters teach us that you
know
Awakening our Enlightenment is bliss is
in the present moment uh eventually I
would imagine and you could explain this
better as we start to keep focusing on
the the vision of the future and feeling
those feelings eventually we do collapse
both and we're in that present elevated
emotional present conscious State at all
times and there's no future to go for
it's just now yeah and imagine being so
whole
uh that you no longer want anything
we've measured this so imagine feeling
so connected to the emotions of your
future you've conditioned your brain and
body into that state if you feel like
your future has already happened you
wouldn't be separate from it in fact you
wouldn't even be looking for it why
would you look for it if it felt like it
already happened that's when the magic
happens that's you when you move closer
and closer into the present moment and
if that Singularity point that Source
energy that the all in all the the
Universal Mind whatever you want to call
it
pure love as you move closer to it then
then the process of creation the process
of healing the process of of doing uh
having a mystical moment would be an
arousal also but the arousal wouldn't be
fear the arousal wouldn't be paying the
arousal wouldn't be aggression or anger
the arousal is actually ecstasy and
we've actually caught this on so many
brain scans that if you're in that state
why would you want to leave the moment
you just and then that's you're moving
closer to source and when that happens
you experience Oneness and Oneness is
when your Consciousness actually merges
with the consciousness of the all in all
and and that should be an arousal and
that should be an Awakening and and the
amount of energy that we capture in the
brain when this occurs the amount of the
amount of um
information being exchanged between the
brain and the Heart Is way way way
outside of normal so getting to the
Sweet Spot of the generous present
moment takes a quite a bit of awareness
and energy because most people wake up
in the morning and they their brain is a
record of the past they start thinking
of their problems those problems are
associated to people that they know the
things that they have to do places they
have to go at certain times and if you
believe that your thoughts have
something to do with your destiny and if
you're waking up in the morning and
you're recalling your past and you're
thinking in the past those are memories
that are etched in the brain now every
one of those problems has an emotion
associated with them so the moment the
person feels unhappy
or feels desperate or feels fear now
their bodies in the past because
thoughts of the vocabulary of the brain
and feelings are the vocabulary of our
bodies and how we think and how we feel
creates our state of being so a thought
and a Feeling
an image and an emotion a stimulus in
response and you're conditioning the
body subconsciously to being in the past
and when we live by familiar emotions
the body's so objective that it's it's
it's believing that it's living in that
same past experience that created that
problem it doesn't know the difference
and if the environment signals the Gene
and it's and the end product of an
experience in the environment is an
emotion
we're we're signaling the gene without
the environment and and if those stress
hormones dysregulate or down regulate
genes and create disease now you're
headed for a genetic future right but
then people can get up after they get
caught up in the way they feel and
reaffirm their identity then they get up
and do a series of routine automatic
behaviors if they'd done the day before
and we could take their yesterday 90 of
their day looks a lot like their
tomorrow and
they become habituated into a
predictable future and if the familiar
past is the known and the predictable
future is the known and that persons
lost their free will
to a set of programs but there's no
unseen hand doing it to them there's no
room for the not anything new to happen
in their life
then if the familiar past is the known
the predictable future is a known
there's only one place where the unknown
exists and that's The Sweet Spot of that
generous present moment and people do
meditations Kelly and they say oh I
can't meditate you know they go oh my
mind's all over the place oh I gotta get
up I gotta check my emails I gotta I got
things to do I get a baby I got kids I
got I got a job and and they they buy
they they buy into the thought that they
can't meditate or it's too hard or
something's wrong with them I need a
brain scan whatever and really that's
just the thought that's causing them to
stay in the known on the other side of
that thought
is freedom and when a person is saying
oh my God it's uh eight o'clock in the
morning and I'm sitting meditating this
is normally when I get in traffic and I
throw a tantrum the body's used to that
don't you think that at eight o'clock in
the morning the body's going to be
looking for that arousal and if you're
not getting it from your outer
environment it'll call up a memory
so that you can feel that emotion and if
you catch yourself doing that
and you settle the body back down into
the present moment that's the moment
you're telling the body it's no longer
the mind that you're the mind and that's
a victory and there's a liberation of
energy that happens we're we're settling
the body down from its animal nature and
then it says I gotta get up I gotta
check my phone I gotta do this I gotta
go there I gotta there and you catch
yourself doing that
and you settle your body back into the
present moment now you're executing a
will
that's greater than the program and
that's a victory as well and it turns
out if you just give people enough time
to sit with themselves we've done this
in 30 week long retreats
uh a person that has to disentangle from
the hardwired thoughts from you know the
habituated actions and the emotional
conditioning that keeps him in the past
and it's if you gotta if you can pay
attention to those thoughts if you can
notice how you're feeling and acting
you're no longer unconscious now you're
conscious and you're outside the program
and it's the act of doing this that
causes us to disentangle and it takes
energy and it takes constant awareness
and it could be a vegetarian you could
be young you could be old you could be
gluten free you could be a wealthy you
could be poor you could be white you
could be black you could be yellow it'd
be any anybody you want you could be
whoever you want everybody
once they learn how to do this when they
can settle into the present moment the
unknown
and nothing dangerous or bad happens
that provokes Adventure it provokes
novelty it provokes the craving for a
new experience a new possibility and
that's where all possibilities exist in
that in that Eternal now and that's when
you go from the realm of space-time you
know space time the three-dimensional
reality where there's an infinite amount
of space we experience time moving
through it to this realm called time
space where there's an infinite amount
of time if you have time as Eternal you
can get a lot of things done there's not
a lot of possibilities equal to your
imagination now when people finally can
settle into the unknown without a name
without a face without a social security
number without a budget without a
profession without kids and just be
aware of themselves
aware of nothing
that has anything to do with the known
physical material world and they create
from nothing that's when something
begins to appear because nothing is the
fundamental ground for everything
physical and
um and three-dimensional also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four learn the skill
of self-regulation how often do you find
yourself in reaction mode code when
someone throws you under the bus whether
it's someone honking at you in a car and
you say ah this how often do you get
back to that place and
like because aren't we conditioned to
kind of react dude I react every day oh
my God I react every day but the
fundamental question is
so shortening the refractory period of
your emotional reactions is that kind of
intelligence where we're keeping
ourselves out of the past Justified
valid or not the only person that that's
affecting is you and then you have to
ask yourself is it loving to me well if
you can't control that emotional
reaction then you're a junkie and you're
on a bad trip and you're overdosing but
if you know that you're overdosing you
got to get beyond your rational mind
because you'll say why are you this way
oh
all right by you doing that is it making
more of those chemicals yeah why well
you're doing that to make you feel more
like it's it's Justified so then
this takes unless I excuse myself
many times in one day because you'll be
I'm in a reaction I'm like are you like
I'll be like are you kidding me what who
what did they do
and then I'll be like oh we're not going
to make a decision in this state so give
me a minute oh wow I go take a few
breaths
get out of that state remember my future
where I'm going it's so much more
important than the present moment I just
got to condition my body into that
future and now it takes
sometimes a Herculean effort I have to
tell you my staff I'll be in my I'll be
in there 15 20 30 minutes sometimes I'll
say I work it took me an hour
but to go back to a piece in in the
expanse of all eternity
if I don't overcome that emotion
then I'm in my past and that's Karma
because that emotion is gonna drive my
behaviors and thoughts and I'm going to
be predictable my past is going to look
my future's gonna look a lot like my
past so if I'm soulfully on the journey
then what matters the most is being able
to learn the skill of self-regulation so
in our in our events when we see people
that can do brain and hard coherence
they know the formula well I look at
their brain scans and I'm like Lewis
Great Brain hey you got you can I I see
you can hold that hard coherence for 45
minutes great now let's put you on a
poll at 55 feet in the air let's get a
heart rate monitor on you and let's see
what you're gonna do up there do you
want to be able to self-regulate there
because if you can there it's not like
I'm trying to give you an adrenaline
rush actually I'm trying to do the
opposite I want you to settle your brain
body back down go against thousands of
years of programming like fear and teach
your body in that moment how to regulate
I guarantee you if you go a little
further than what you did and you stay
conscious instead of throwing in a
program and rushing through it and
trying to get it over with you start
breathing you start getting back in your
heart you start getting sent and you
work against those chemicals I guarantee
you when you walk into your life
you're gonna the moment you see
something you're gonna catch on right
away You're Gonna Catch yourself now
that that saves you a lot of energy
and a lot of time because if you're able
to change it then instead of four hours
later where you're just yeah gone or
you've already reacted yeah and and
you've done things you said I you say I
should have never done that I should
have never said that that's what those
emotions do because those emotions make
us really primitive rule number five
have a purpose bigger than you what's
the most important thing based on your
experience in life in work in in general
to be successful in life whatever
success means for you hmm
I think that when people reach the point
where they and this has happened to me
and it's happened to many people in our
community
where they reach a certain level a
certain status where they have
everything they need
the fundamental thing that happens to
those people is that they start thinking
about how am I going to make a
difference in the world what Legacy
what what am I going to leave how am I
going to make a difference or change the
world in some way
so so we think we want all those things
but really what we want to do is really
contribute so I think when we have a
purpose that's bigger than us it's the
highest form of motivation Mission
motivation Duty motivation purpose
motivation when we have a selfless
Vision that's bigger than us I think
we're wired to be that that the living
organism called the species of human
beings it is a living organism then
these in this current ERA the age of
selfish individuality has to die
that we are a species and the species of
a living organism takes care of one
another they heal one another they
educate one another they teach one
another they Inspire one another
they give to one another they they serve
one another that's that's what a living
organism does they they cooperate
communicate collaborate with one another
that's uh that's what it does and so
we are we are wired
to be communal we are wired to create
common Unity community and that
Community is built on the frequency of
love and when you come from love you you
come from a different Consciousness it's
no longer about you you feel so amazing
you feel this feeling that isn't going
away
that the only thing you want to do is
have other people feel what you're
feeling and the only way we do that is
to give we say I feel so amazing I want
you to feel the way I feel so I don't
need this here take that that kind of
community
is goes counter to the current situation
in the world where everything's breaking
down but this is a Time
where we have to demonstrate what that
new community looks like so when you
have connection when you have Community
when you have true friendship
the person's really just giving because
there's something unusual about them and
you're worthy enough to receive
and you feel that feeling of receiving
that you want to give to somebody else
you how you create a very different
Consciousness you create a common Unity
or a community that's bonded and
connected in the frequency of love and
then when love is the common frequency
it's very difficult to break that
Community up because it's the glue that
holds them together so that's my vision
of where I'd like to go with this work
I'm rule number six the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is use the
power of meditation how can the power of
meditation change past traumas
experience and memories
yeah well that's a great question well
think about this a memory is just where
neurons actually connect
and so you learn a bit of information
right you learn you learn you learn how
to ride a bike you read a book about it
you read a book on how to cook uh
Mandarin Cuisine you read a book on how
to dance the salsa all of that
information is stored in your thinking
neocortex right so it's philosophical
so a person has a trauma right the
stronger the emotion that they have from
that event the more altered they are
inside of them the more the brain
freezes a frame and takes a snapshot and
that's called the long-term memory and
that image or those series of images are
embossed neurologically in the brain so
the stronger the emotion the more we pay
attention to the cause and that's what
creates the memory now here's the
problem
the problem is that when we think about
that problem when we review we remember
that that that past event we're
producing the same chemistry in the
brain and body as if the event was
happening now the body's so objective
it doesn't know the difference Alex
between the real life experience that's
creating the emotion and the emotion
that the person is experiencing by
thought alone so the body's believing
it's living in the same past experience
24 hours a day seven days a week 365
days a year
and so
now the person can't think greater than
how they feel so they feel sadness they
feel guilt they feel pain they feel
suffering they feel hostility and those
emotions tend to drive the same thoughts
for them to remember the reason why they
feel this way and so people get caught
in these Loops of thinking and feelings
so
that creates a state of being right so
thoughts are the language of the brain
and feelings are the language of the
body and how we think and how we feel
creates our state of being
so without the person knowing this by
reviewing and remembering the problem
they're taking a thought and a feeling
an image and an emotion a stimulus and a
response and their conditioning their
body emotionally into the past now the
trauma
does not only exist in the brain
the trauma now exists in the body too as
an emotional memory
so if the person can't think greater
than how they feel and they believe that
their thoughts have something to do with
their destiny
they're thinking in the past and if
you're thinking in the past you create
more of the same life
so we started noticing that when people
are altered when they're angry when
they're frustrated when they're stressed
when they're fearful when they're
suffering when they're in pain
the arousal of those emotions switches
on our primitive nervous system that
causes the brain and body to go into
stress or survival and when we're in
stress and when we're in survival we're
always trying to predict the next moment
based on what we've learned in the past
and stress is Created from the loss of
control the inability to predict what's
going to happen and the perception that
things are going to get worse so seventy
percent of the time people are living in
a state of stress and living in survival
it's not a time to create
it's not a time to open your heart it's
not a time to be vulnerable it's not a
time to learn it's time to run fight or
hide yeah and also all the inflammations
in the body and all the life diseases
they want to grow that way exactly so so
now we were looking at to see what
happens to the brain well when we're in
stress and that person's in trauma
and they're trying to control everything
in their life they're shifting their
attention from one person to another
person to another problem to another
thing to another place to another object
and every one of those elements has a
neurological Network in their brain so
the arousal of the stress hormones
causes their brain to fire very
incoherently now
when our brains are incoherent we're
incoherent when our brains aren't
working right we're not working right so
so the the obsession of the stress
hormones causes us to narrow our focus
on whatever is whatever the causes so
when we're in stress we obsess we we
Loop we overthink we narrow our focus on
something so we thought my goodness
there's some research out there that
shows that if you teach people to
broaden their focus
to begin to instead of focusing on
everything material and physical that's
causing the stress everything that's
known broaden their focus and put their
attention on space on nothing and the
act of doing that
causes the brain to begin to synchronize
to begin to unify to become more
coherent and what sinks in the brain
links in the brain so the person's brain
starts functioning normally and starts
to improve without any medications
without any therapies just a simple Act
and the more they do it
the more order that creates that's
created in their brain the more they can
focus their attention and move into a
more creative state what do I want how
successful do I want to be how healthy
do I want to be how much love do I want
in my life you can ask the bigger
questions by the same means
when the person is gripped by those
hormones of stress and they're not
running
from that Predator they're not fighting
and they're not freezing and hiding but
the chemicals are running their heart is
beating because it's in an aroused state
but it's beating against the closed
system and the Heart starts beating
incoherently when that happens energy
leaves the heart and we stop trusting we
stop believing in ourselves so
we teach people how to create brain and
hard coherence and what we discovered
just in the last couple years is that
when this heart starts beating orderly
and it's a skill just like anything else
you do like dancing in the South like
you when you understand all that
information and now you're in the
application of it once you start to
experience it and you get the feeling of
what it feels like to be in the state it
turns out
that when the heart is coherent it
starts informing the brain you'll see it
the brain's starting to change because
the heart is telling the brain
it's time to create now it's safe to
create it's the creative Center
so the person all of a sudden can see a
possibility that they never could see
before and they can embrace the emotion
of the event listen closely before the
experience happens now this is
fundamentally important because most
people are waiting for their Wells to
feel abundant and worthy they're waiting
for their success to feel empowerment
they're waiting for the new relationship
to feel loved they're waiting for their
healing to feel gratitude
that's cause and effect that's waiting
for something outside the change to take
away this feeling of emptiness or lack
or pain or guilt or whatever we found
out that when a person can actually
embrace the emotion
before the event
they can begin to condition their brain
and body into a future experience and
the brain and body don't know the
difference so all of a sudden a person
who was traumatized
and had their had their experience now
all of a sudden they're teaching their
body emotionally how to live in a new
environment and the body doesn't know
the difference between the real life
experience and the one that they're
fabricating so in a sense
thereby creating brain and heart
coherence
the stronger the emotion they feel for
their new vision of their future
the more they're going to pay attention
to the picture in their mind and they're
literally remembering their future
and now there's biological changes in
gene expression in neurological
circuitry and brain coherence and immune
regulation in digestive balance in
microbiomes and all the things we
measure show the bodies now out of
survival
it's time for growth and repair so the
side effect of that is we see people
with those serious health conditions
that were actually initiated because of
the trauma
all of a sudden when they feel that
elevated emotion it's like they've taken
their body out of the past
into the present moment and now the body
all of a sudden recalibrates and if the
quotient of their excitement for their
new life for their new future the
emotional quotient of their dream is
greater than the Betrayal or the shock
or the trauma
there's immediate reorganization in the
brain and an immediate change
emotionally in the body and now the
person looks back at their past and
we've interviewed enough people
to know this is the truth and they say
I don't want to change anything in my
past
I I all of that brought me to this
moment and that's the moment the past no
longer exists so people can have a
brutal past where we've had people that
have had an abuse physical sexual um
emotional
that have gone through all kinds of
abuse where suicidal had all kinds of
health conditions and in one instant in
one instant one inner experience from
the meditative process
begins to change everything about the
way they see their past or seeing it
from a greater level of Consciousness
they're seeing it from a place of Love
they're seeing that all of that had to
happen
it makes sense to get to this point and
now they're no longer victimized by
their disease they're no longer
victimized by their past
you get your ass kicked along the way
things go sideways things go wrong
people let you down Partners don't work
out money falls out all these things
happen but I want you to reframe it in
your mind success auditor success tax
auditor is looking looking and going
okay let's put another obstacle in front
of Wendy's way let's see if she can get
through that oh she saw the obstacle
turn around went back I don't think
she's going to be the one that reaches
her full potential but she could just
live life like everybody else and she'll
be okay let's see about liberio let's
see what's up Liberia let's throw some
crap in front of him let's throw some
fears in front of him let's throw a
massive obstacle wow
he fought it he was a little sad it was
a little tough a little stressful a
couple sleepless nights but he's still
going okay check that box let's wait
about three months and throw some more
in his way and that's what I believe
success tax is I think we have to go
through the trials and tribulates we
have to build the grit we have to build
the wisdom
or else we don't deserve it I teach my
daughter she's killing it in softball I
said you win when no one else is
watching you have to pay your success
tax by practicing all the time when no
one's cheering no one's excited no one's
doing it over the summer she's down here
in my office pitching because she's
paying her success tax but guess what in
the fall when she plays she's gonna kill
it when she comes out and all her
friends will be like oh my God
everybody's admiring you you got the
game ball I wish I could do that you
wish you could do it pay success tax
if you're not willing to pay get out of
the freaking game don't think it is
listen everybody wants to be on stage in
front of 50 000 people jamming and
singing with everybody going crazy in
the crowd singing their name but you
know what everybody's not willing to do
is play in their room until their
fingers bleed to pack up an old van and
drive around to Gig to Gig when two
people show up most people aren't
willing to do that everybody looks at
the Beatles on how amazing they were
right you know the Beatles paid played
like 10 000 different uh over over the
years they played almost every night
like six nights a week sometimes two
gigs a night for years and years and
years never being noticed sometimes one
person in the audience they paid their
success tax and then all of a sudden
they were an overnight sensation they
weren't an overnight sensation so think
of it that way frame it as success tax
is part of the journey and if you could
say I'm not saying you need to like the
crap
I'm not saying you have to like the
journey not saying you have to like when
somebody screws you over the deal goes
sideways but what if you could go wow if
I get through this I get another check
box from the success tax auditor you
start looking at life that way things
change and you realize you're here
because you're learning those skills to
get through them easier and quicker most
of the world most of the world sees a
wall and they turn around and go back
they're not deserving of the success you
are the type that will pound through it
get under it get around it climb over it
or blow it up with dynamite and that's
who wins the game so with that said
let's take it a step further
because I can talk about this until I'm
blue and like I could talk about this
every moment of every day when it comes
to my business because I've crushed it
in my business those fears that I had of
being a broke kid I didn't I didn't have
the right education I didn't go to
college I didn't have money I didn't
come from the right Town my parents both
worked to make you know probably 35
Grand combined separately and we always
stressed about money and I lived in a
bathroom with my dad I lived in a
trailer park with my mom until we got
evicted I mean crazy stuff right in
business I overcame all those fears I
failed miserably Winston Churchill said
the definition of success is going from
failure to failure without losing your
enthusiasm well I I did that before I
ever read that quote when I kept going I
paid my success tax I failed miserably
and I made it and in business I can make
those decisions I can I can fail
miserably I can lose millions of dollars
on a deal and I can be over in a day I
could I could have faith in someone I'm
working with and they let me down and it
hurts and I'm over in a day I can
rebound fast learn from it and go I have
trained my body I've trained my my my
insides I've trained my physiology I've
trained my words I've trained my
subconscious that we are freaking
Unstoppable nothing as a combined body
and unit nothing can stop us have you
ever spent any time wondering how does
everything happen how does everything
happen why does the night follow the day
why doesn't the day follow the day
like in some places it does
but
I spent a lot of time thinking about
this
after times it almost drives me crazy
the like right outside of my studio here
is a Japanese maple tree
and
there's times of the year it's
absolutely beautiful
in the spring of the year it has buds on
and then the buds cologne and leaves pop
out and the leaves generally in the
spring are a very deep greeny Brown
they're not a pretty looking leaf
but then they start to change and over
time you don't notice it happening just
one day you look and it's a different
color
and by fall
the leaves are crimson red they're the
most beautiful it is the most beautiful
tree and it's right outside in my studio
I'm sitting here in my desk and
cameras around me but oh there it is
that tree
and you know every fall the leaves turn
red
Every Spring there are greeny brown
they're not greeny brown in the fall and
red in the spring they're always red in
the faux and greeny brown in the spring
think about it did you ever wonder why
the tide goes way out the tide comes way
back in
I spent some time in the Navy in Canada
I was down on the East Coast for a while
and I was near the Bay of Fundy do you
know the Bay of Fundy has one of the
highest and lowest tides in the world
it's absolutely amazing it goes way out
and then comes way back in
same upper on Prince George on the West
Coast
you go onto a ship and you might be
walking up a plank just right straight
up and you go off the ship sometimes
you're going right down that ship goes
way up in here and it comes way down
very high very low tide now some place
the tides not very big they do have a
time but not too high not too long
why is it so different in one place than
another
you know why does the leaves change
color
why do they change color
you know why does the grass keep growing
wouldn't it be so much nicer it's a
grass just you know just stayed at a
certain length you wouldn't have to cut
it but it would always look pretty
you know do you ever think about this do
you know that everything in this
universe happens in an exact way
and exact way not by chance but in an
exact way
when John Kennedy the president of the
United States acted asked Dr Warner Von
Braun who was The Mastermind behind the
space program we asked him what would it
take to build a rocket that would carry
a person to the moon and bring them back
safely to Earth
Von Braun answered him in five words the
will to do it that's it the will to do
it
he knew he didn't have to know how to do
it he knew he had to learn how to do it
but he didn't have to know to make up
your mind you were going to do it now
why did he say that because he
understands the laws
Vine brown one time said after years of
studying the spectacular Mysteries of
the cosmos he was led into a firm belief
in the existence of God and he said the
natural laws of this universe are so
precise that we don't even have any
difficulty building spaceship we send
people to the moon and we can find the
landing with the Precision of a fraction
of a second
now he said these laws must have been
set by someone I see the laws as God's
modus operandi but I'm going to tell you
something everything happens by law when
you and I get in harmony with the law I
never do that odds are pretty good we
should understand them but when we get
in harmony with the law then I'm going
to tell you it's just smooth sailing
success
happens
probably be a good understand good idea
to understand the laws wouldn't it
think about it
your life is governed by laws that are
not man-made so they're not going to be
man changed and if you study them and
work in harmony with them I'm going to
go shock yourself with the good you can
do now I've been doing that for the last
58 years I'm starting to get a really a
reasonable grip on them but I don't
understand them as well as I want to or
would like to
but I'm going to study a little more
today you know I get my trusty book out
here I'll have to talk to you about this
part that'll be another talk
study the laws find out what they write
what they're like
what are the laws and then study them
you'll win before you can be a painter
who can paint what's beyond mere memory
you you have to inculcate that
discipline skill and a lot of that is
painful repetition and hard grinding
work it's the sacrifice of the present
for the future but once you manage that
then things open up and virtually
everything you learn of value is like
that's very very very difficult to learn
to write and there's arbitrary arbitrary
rules that you have to follow and bind
yourself to and while you're learning
those rules the probability that you
have any creative freedom to speak of or
any facility with the rules is very low
you're you're a rank beginner and and
even to some degree whatever creativity
you have is going to have to be stifled
while you're passing through that that
Keyhole but if you pass through it then
something massive opens up on the other
side and it is definitely the case that
disciplinary institutions universities
are exactly that is there places of
guidance and and their places to
encourage people to develop the
discipline that's necessary to see
beyond the discipline I mean that's why
we have disciplines right I mean the
words aren't there by accident you have
to narrow yourself first and then you
can broaden outward and so that's and
that's part of the process of maturation
that part of the that's part of the
sacrifice of childhood say in childhood
you're nothing but potential but it's
not realized and you don't know how to
realize it and so then the question is
well how do you get to a point where you
realize the potential and the answer is
you sacrifice almost all of it to a
single Direction This is Nietzsche's
commentary on the Catholic Church he's a
great admirer of the Catholic Church
despite the fact that he was also a
radical critic critic of Christianity
said the cat see the thing about the
Catholic church is that it forced
everything to be interpreted within a
single explanatory framework and that
was a disciplined and once that
discipline was established then the
disciplined mind could explode in every
direction which is precisely what
happened and so and and and that's the
thing about growing up is that when
you're a teenager and a young adult you
have to sacrifice everything you could
have been as a child to be the one thing
that you're aiming at but then that
opens up and and the universities are
part and parcel of that process and you
need the guidance because the the the
library is too large to wander through
it unaided your personality literally ad
is made up of how you think how you act
and how you feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life so then
if you want to change your life your
personal reality you got to change your
personality and here we go again you got
to start becoming conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to start
noticing how you act how you speak you
got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that you begin to objectify your
subjective self so so then
when you begin to make small changes
back the thought a new thought should
lead to a new Choice a new Choice should
lead to a new Behavior a new Behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth
right so then the new emotion should
Inspire new thoughts and that's called
Evolution so how do we get stuck it's
really simple
the stronger the emotion you feel from
some event in your life be it a betrayal
or a trauma or whatever yes the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
you pay attention to the cause outside
of you so the brain takes a snapshot it
freezes an image and embosses that
pattern neurologically in the brain
that's called a memory so we create
long-term memories from strong emotional
events okay so is that true that I just
want to understand the maybe the larger
the event in terms of its emotion to you
the stronger of a hold it has over you
yeah well the more it's embossed in your
biology so some certain people have a
strong experience in their life and it
catches all of the brain's attention so
now they think neurologically within the
circuits of the past experience and they
feel chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and so how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
now here's the problem
that if you don't know how to mediate or
control your emotional reaction to that
event and you keep that refractory
period of chemicals going on with
extended periods of time so that the
event produces a chemical change and the
body needs to return back to homeostasis
or balance but if it can't then the
elongation of that emotional reaction
for weeks say for days or weeks is
called the moon so you say Ed what's
wrong with you I'm in a mood why are you
in a mood well this thing happened to me
five days ago and I'm having one long
emotional reaction so then what you do
is you keep telling the story about it
keep firing and wiring the same circuits
and you keep conditioning the body into
the past so then you wake up in the
morning you look for the emotion
so then now all of a sudden you keep it
lingering for for for weeks or months
that's called the temperament well why
is he so angry I don't know let's ask
him why are you so angry well this thing
happened to me eight months ago I'm
having one long emotional reaction I'm
memorizing my emotions you keep it going
on for years on end that's called a
personality trait so then a person then
is memorizing themselves by living in
the past and so then you say to them
well well tell me the story now the
latest research on memory says that 50
percent of what we talk about in our
past isn't even the truth so we make
stuff up about the past in other words
people are reliving a life that they
didn't even have just to reaffirm that
they can't change right wow so then
what's the significance of this where
you place your attention is where you
place your energy period yes so then the
stronger the emotion that you have the
some problem or condition or person in
your life the more you're paying
attention to them so they captured your
attention so you're giving your power
away to that person right because
they're capturing your attention so then
there's an energetic connection to every
person everything everything in your
past present reality has your energy
connected to it so now this is the
significance when a person really
decides to be defined by a vision of the
future instead of the memory of the past
the hardest part about it is all of a
sudden becoming conscious and not making
the same unconscious choice so then
if you lower the volume to your
frustration to your hatred to your anger
if you truly knew how to do that if you
lower the volume to that emotion you
would take your attention off that
person which means you would begin to
break those energetic bonds and now
you're taking your power back yes you're
calling energy back to you and we've
measured this and all of a sudden it
builds this bigger electronic magnetic
field around the person's body that's
energy to heal that's energy to create a
new future with right and then if you
didn't want to lower the volume to the
emotion then just take your attention
off the person and every time you take
your attention off the person if you
became conscious of that you wouldn't
feel the emotion now the body though
it's been addicted to that emotion
because you're using that person to
reaffirm your addiction to hatred or
frustration and if that person died
you'd find another one so then here you
go now so
now you're in a position now where you
begin to lower the volume to that
emotion and the body's going wait a
second you've been you've been doing
this for the last 20 years and all of a
sudden you're just going to stop hating
and the body says well I've been
conditioned this way and conditioning is
based on the past so when the body feels
the the lack of that emotion just like a
drug addict it says hey you're off
schedule here so now the body starts
influencing the mind to think about
experiences that are embossed in the
brain that are based on that emotion so
the emotion now is causing you to think
in the past if we teach a person then
how to trade that frustration or that
hatred for an elevated emotion and
they'll say yeah but you know it was my
ex's fault or I got betrayed by my
partner in business yeah yeah we know
that okay so let's take your partner in
business or take your ex let's duct tape
them put them in a cannon and shoot them
to the moon now what are you gonna do
sooner or later you got to reckon with
yourself and change right so then
teach a person then how to trade that
emotion for an elevated emotion now
trade the emotion for an elevated
emotion right so you're going to give
that up and you're going to practice
feeling gratitude for as an example yes
the person says well I can't feel
gratitude and I say absolutely you can
because you don't practice feeling it
you practice spending most of your time
feeling hatred and frustration so now
it's going to take a little time to
cause that heart of you to bloom or
you're part of yours to bloom once
they're able to feel even the smallest
measure of gratitude where they start
feeling appreciation thankfulness
gratitude its emotional signature when
you when you get something when you're
receiving something
when something has happened to you
uh or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature
of gratitude means the event has already
happened or it's happening to you so the
moment you open your heart and you feel
gratitude well that emotion then is
telling the body that the experience has
already occurred and the thought then
can make it into the body because it's
consistent with the thought so now
you're beginning to program the
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific Destiny you got to maintain
that modified State of Mind and Body
your entire day independent of the
conditions in your outer environment
independent of your body's Cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can get
ready because something weird or unusual
some synchronicity some coincidence some
opportunity is going to land in your lap
and you didn't have to go and get it yes
it came to you now you're the vortex of
creation so if you say to me well I was
feeling gratitude but then there was
traffic or my co-worker sent me a nasty
email that I would say oh my God God you
mean you're allowing your environment
your outer environment to control how
you feel and think you're back to the
unconscious program that you're the
victim to your life you got it but when
you start producing those outcomes in
your life you're going to pay attention
to what you did inside of you and you're
going to believe more that you're the
creator of your life and less of the
victim of your life consistent action is
the cure-all whatever problem you have
whatever issue you're facing whatever
big life you want to create for yourself
the way to get there is not some giant
short burst of effort it's the daily
consistent grinding action that will
help you accomplish your goals people
look at my channel and
a lot of new people have joined over the
past number of years hey welcome board
great to have you welcome to believe
Nation it's a positive happy place it's
great to have you here it's an honor to
be a part of your daily routine
if you go and look at my my channel my
main channel in the history it took so
many years guys so many years of just
making content and not seeing any
results
I took I forget what the number is it
took five years to get to 9 000
something subscribers and another five
years to get almost two million
subscribers now sitting over three
million subscribers Etc
I haven't missed
an upload every single day
for I don't know
eight years
something crazy like that
every day
I've made videos through
travel I've made videos through elect
electricity electricity outages I made
videos through breaking my neck I made
videos through my tour I made videos
through vacation I made videos I made
videos I made videos I made videos I
made videos I made videos and you can
plan you can prepare you can get ahead
you can you can batch them
but I don't think your goals count until
they're hard
it's when it gets hard when when you get
tested that's when you have to show
yourself What You're Made Of
even little things like
I remember filming at my dance studio in
Toronto
and I have my camera guy and my
assistant and we're filming and the
electricity goes out
and then there's a fire alarm
they go I guess we can't film like the
first thing that that my camera guy says
is okay well I guess we can't film I
can't film with this like electricity
outage and then fire alarm
fire alarm
you can't film with that it's like I'm
I'm filming today
so I took my phone it was freezing
outside I took my phone went outside and
just started filming
because videos have to go up
they have to go up
I've I've made videos with my broken
neck
I broke my neck in two spots had a
concussion
and I
next week I'm making videos
they weren't as long they weren't as
good
I'm wearing a neck brace if you look at
the old videos I'm wearing this giant
neck brace I got this giant scab here on
my forehead because I smashed my head
against the wall
when I fainted and that's how it led to
the concussion broken neck I'm still
making videos
not making videos is not an option
and so if you look at someone like me
who
is introverted is shy who doesn't like
the camera who always thought that
people who were famous had a big ego who
I still don't like being on stage I
still get nervous every single time
but I still have a message
and I still want to serve how does
somebody like that
have this kind of Channel well because
of every single day making videos you've
done over 10 000 videos I've done over
10 000 videos that's crazy
not all of them are public
but even just on the main Channel let
alone this channel on the top 10 channel
the other channel 10 000 Plus videos
over 12 years
why
how
it's just a consistent action
I think most people lose because
we overestimate what we can do
in a really
short period of time and underestimate
what we can do in a long period of time
you think by putting in three weeks of
hard work you're gonna crush it
but really if you just stayed on it like
guys you've had ideas you have enough
you have had an idea
that you'd love that you gave up on too
soon that if you just kept doing it this
is an idea that you had maybe three
years ago that if you just found the way
to keep doing it even part-time even on
the side even on the weekends if you
just kept at it you'd be in a different
place right now
something would have happened something
would have paid off
but we're too frustrated to get
something to happen right now and I get
it I'm there too I'm I'm impatient I
want immediate results I want things to
happen I'm putting my best I want this
video right now to be the best one I've
ever done and I put my effort to try to
make that happen and I fully recognize
at the same time that
it's a long game
that you have to keep going
and that it's your purpose you can't
give up on it
most people just quit too soon
you just quit too soon
and that's you quitting on your dream
and if it's your dream and you want it
to happen it's a daily consistent
action to make it happen
so how do you do it let me give you some
tactics so that you can not just get
motivated from a message but actually
apply it to your life number one you
have to create a calendar
these videos happen because you're in my
calendar
I'm filming this on a Tuesday
is my YouTube day I always film on
Tuesday I block it off in my calendar
I just came back from vacation and on
the Tuesday of my week I was still
making videos people say well we still
work on vacation first off it's not work
like I like this this is fun for me this
isn't this isn't oh I have to go make
videos if that was my mindset I would
I'd be out I wouldn't do it anymore
but also if you're on vacation you're
making videos or you're doing a little
bit of work
spend three hours
of a 24-hour day
doing something
is totally achievable somebody one of
the people that I invested into
yesterday's like how do I take a
vacation on my business
like how do I my wife wants to know how
do I go on vacation and run this
business like you can still you can
either plan ahead and get ahead with all
your clients or you can still do some
work
do you not have personal time are you
going to be around your wife 24 hours a
day does your wife not want to go to the
spa or spend some time on the beach it's
not about the three hours that you spend
working it's about
the other hours at 21 hours you get to
sleep but whatever all the other hours
that you have the day it's about
intentional time most of most people's
life is not intentional most of your
vacation time is not intentional either
if you were to spend 21 hours a day with
your wife
intentionally creating an amazing
relationship
then the three hours a day you're going
to spend working
as easy as nothing
she could take time off
but you have to put in your calendar
you have to create a calendar that makes
sense for you
schedule in when you're actually going
to make your dreams happen because
otherwise it's a dream I could say I
want to make YouTube videos but if it
was never my calendar guess what it
would never happen and this applies for
life too every uh every afternoon
at 2 30 I spend time with Nina with my
wife
we spend time in the morning I take an
intentional break at 2 30 we go to the
park we take we take the dogs with us
we we stay inside and just be together
if it's raining like we'll spend time
every day every weekday at 2 30 because
I want I wanted to spend more time with
Nina during the week weekends we're
basically all in on on the relationship
but the weekdays can be crazy you know
so we spend time in the morning we spend
time in the evening and I wanted to
spend 2 30. it's 25 minutes together but
intentional 25 minutes that intentional
25 minutes is worth more than three
hours of just sitting in front of a TV
that's not time together
you have a lot more time than you think
just not being intentional that's the
problem if you feel like you got to the
end of the week and you were so busy but
you got nothing done
and everything's falling apart you're
just not intentional with your time
so you schedule it in whatever you want
in a life whatever your dream life looks
like whatever your goals Ambitions
motivations are put in your calendar
two
be the person who follows through on
their calendar
stop letting yourself off the hook
for not following through on your
calendar
I'm a little tired today because we just
came back from our trip I'm a little jet
lagged from coming out from the West
I'm still making videos I'm still videos
have to be made they're going up like
when do you let yourself break
if it's in the calendar it has to happen
videos have to happen today I don't care
if I'm lying in bed I don't care I don't
care if I'm in the hospital I've made
videos from the hospital I don't care
where videos have to come up I don't
care if they're the best videos the best
with what I can make right now
if I'm tired they might be lower than my
standard
but it's the best of what I can make
right now if I'm in the hospital it's
definitely lower than what I can make
out of the hospital but I'm gonna make
the best of what I can make right now
be the person who follows through on the
things that you say you're gonna do
because the next time you put something
in your calendar the next time we see
you're gonna get that goal or
do this project you're gonna the next
day wake up and say I'm not I can't do
that I'm not doing that
you're starting to build the identity
either way of the person who follows
through or the person who doesn't follow
through
and every time you say yes to yourself
every time you do it when it's difficult
you start to build up that identity a
little bit more I follow through I
follow through I follow through so then
the next time you put something in your
calendar the next time come up with a
goal you start to believe that it's
actually possible for you to do it
because you're building that identity of
you being the person who actually
follows through
and every time you let yourself off the
hook every time you give yourself a
break every time you say it's okay I'm
not going to do it today every time you
say that you
eat away at that other identity and
start to build a new one
the new identity of the person who
doesn't follow through
you start to believe yourself a little
bit less
the next goal you write down is a little
less credible you don't think you can do
it you're going to realize the next day
that you're not going to follow through
it says it's a very
slippery slope to fall down
so step one is you build a calendar step
two is you become the person who sticks
to your calendar
who follows through on the things that
you say you're gonna do that's why it's
important to create a realistic calendar
don't tell me don't tell yourself you're
gonna make 100 videos a day every day
you're going to make a thousand phone
calls a day every day
you're not you're gonna write a hundred
love letters to your wife every day
you're not you're not it's not going to
happen make it a realistic plan for
something you can actually stick to
because again if you just stick to it
guys you will hit your goals
if you stop quitting on yourself if you
stop letting yourself off the hook that
idea you had three years ago should have
already come to Creation because you
just stuck with it just stick with it
step number three so create a calendar
one stick to your calendar number two
three
the environment around you really
matters
videos like this really matters why I
create the inspressor to be with you
every morning to give you the Boost to
bring you people like John asraaf and
Oprah and Elon Musk and these people who
lift you up who inspire you hopefully
that's the intention every time
join a group like movement makers be a
part of a community be around other
entrepreneurs who are doing things we're
chasing their dreams we're trying to
make their thing happen when you're when
you create that environment and you
start to shift it
it inspires you to want to play bigger
it inspires you to want to stay
consistent when you are feeling at your
lowest low when you're about to quit on
the thing that you said that you want to
do that's in your calendar you see it
you see it today I'm supposed to do that
like I don't want to do that what brings
you out of it
it's the habits it's the environment
it's the routine
watch another video
join our group like movement makers
get a mentor coach
have an accountability buddy
you have to be around the people who
constantly fill your cup who give you
light who lift you up who make you
believe and help you feel like it's
possible when you do those three things
your life will change
create a calendar
that mapped your actions to your
ambitions
be the person who follows through on
their calendar
and then be around the people videos
resources environment
that encourages you that lifts you up
and makes you feel like it's possible
[Music]
no I I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
how to manifest 10 times faster check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there you'd have to become
aware of your unconscious habits and
behaviors and even what you say and
modify them and then you'd have to look
at those emotions that keep you anchored
to the past and decide if those emotions
belong in your future